okay we have a voicemail number two one
nine to david p this today's caller was
upset about what he calls the bad
quality of the voicemails that are
played on the show let's take a listen
to what he had to say the only voicemail
you play on a crappy one and then you
complain that you get fifty a day just
play the good ones stop saying the
crappy ones and maybe the crappy people
will stop leaving crappy ones and i want
my message to be positive so let me say
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
I love how indignant this caller is what
you have to understand is yeah we get
sometimes we get 50 voicemails in a day
first of all the three-minute voicemails
that get cut off because the three
minutes isn't even enough for the caller
to put together one thought start to
finish those aren't going to get played
so once you eliminate the back-to-back
three-minute calls you no longer have 50
you probably have more like 20 we did
that yesterday but that was more of a
public service announcement it was just
to people to understand what's going on
of the 20 that we have left a lot of
them are sort of messages not really for
air there's sort of like direct messages
to me that don't really make any sense
as voicemails on the show so that cuts
it down and then when you actually get
to the dozen or so that are more
reasonable half of them you can barely
hear what the person saying because
they're either calling from the car or
with loud music blaring in the
background or on some kind of bizarre
speakerphone or weird interference that
sounds like birds chirping and an
old-school dial-up modem so I'm actually
often only left with like three or four
even possible voicemails for each day
and I make the best assessment from
those three or four you know and the
funny thing is and I may get some flack
for this yeah that was a crappy
voicemail voicemail but hey I
guess he's right because it was a crappy
voicemail and it made it onto the show
yeah which means that the guy is kind of
right and he's been engaged he's
indicated we've got a great bonus show
today a train carrying members of
Congress hit a truck and one person did
die tragically killer whales I call them
orcas I feel like killer whale is a
little bit bad reputation yeah orcas
have learned to imitate human speech
in a world-first and a British Lord
offered his resignation after showing up
late to work can you imagine the respect
for the position that that something
Donald Trump could really learn from
david pakman.com slash membership and
patreon.com slash david pakman show are
the two ways to get instant access to
the bonus show